you
sorry for being late start almost on
time and immediately will tell us but
deterministic population comes important
us me too so much Santa yes okay so
happy I you say because the dependence
on the number of functions is going to a
triply exponential maybe the hunt does
will make it dissipate no ok so we saw a
lot of LDS PD of action in the last stop
itself but I'm still going to recap the
definition in one slide so the object of
interest in this talk the greedy pts so
that is nothing but a boolean function
of the form sign of a polynomial where
the polynomial is of degree D so f
equals sign of p where degree of PSD
here the domain is defined to be minus 1
1 to the n so the hypercube but you can
take the domain to be R to the N and
equipped with any measure and four in
this stuff we are just going to focus on
the case when T equals two okay so
cutting to the chase the problem we're
interested in is the following you are
given K degree two pts f point to FK
over the boolean hypercube and a
function G a boolean function G on the K
dimensional hypercube and you want to
deterministically compute the quantity
that if you choose a random point from
the N dimensional hypercube what's the
probability the G of f one to FK
evaluates to 1 so this is the hunt of
degree two pdfs because we are thinking
of g as having a DK which is constant so
thats why we are calling it a hunter
answering adams question and we don't
want to estimate the core we don't want
to compute this quantity exactly because
they're sharp be hard to compute so we
will be happy with deterministic we will
be happy with additive approximations so
I just want to compute this probability
up to an additive
epsilon welcome already did some survey
of this kind of stuff in this last stop
but let me just quickly go over the
motivation okay so sorry another
important thing is that we would like
the running time to be some fixed
polynomial in n times some function of K
and epsilon in particular another way to
rephrase this thing is that we would
like the running time to remain
polynomial in N for even case which are
slightly super constant and epsilon
which is slightly sub constant on the
other hand if the running time was n
raise to K or something like that then e
for any super constant K the running
time will not be polynomial so
motivation Rocco covered a lot of
motivation for this kind of
deterministic counting in the last talk
so that that's the first bullet but
really any interesting class of problems
as a property that the counting version
is sharply hard and say dnf counting or
accounting for half spaces and in fact
and this is what motivates the study of
approximate counting in the first place
yeah no no it does it's been a nurse
with better people and of all the
meanings associated there okay oh and I
know this is the adjective really have
any of a meaning which okay for boolean
functions from the perspective boolean
functions in fact even the decision
versions of the problem just deciding
whether this one satisfying assignment
versus no satisfying assignment most of
these classes will have the property
that even this decision problem will be
np-hard and hence you cannot even hope
to get multiplicative approximation
guarantees for the counting problem in
polynomial time so the only reasonable
problem left in the landscape of the
approximate counting problems is that ok
so the only thing you can now hope to do
is get added to the additive
approximations to the counting problem
okay and as rock again mentioned in the
last talk there is a simple trivial
sampling based algorithm which given any
efficiently computable function can get
a additive epsilon added accurate
estimate of the faction of satisfying
assignments just sound of sampling works
so okay so the only interesting problem
left is that we would like to
deterministically approximate the
fraction of satisfying assignments for a
given class of boolean functions there's
the only interesting problem left yeah
yeah and so yeah yeah so so you can
consider two classes of problems here
one is that you give a given a the
algorithm will actually look at the
given function or there is some sort of
an oblivious algorithm like a
pseudo-random generator so we are
considering the weaker problem here
where the algorithm will actually look
at the problem will look at the given
instance and then do the approximate
counting okay so this was all motivation
but there is another motivation really
for this thing it's known that if we can
do very strong circuit lower bounds that
implies that every efficient randomized
algorithm can be Duran demised and
proving the hypothesis is really out of
question at the moment so we should do
the next best thing prove the
consequence so we should try to consider
specific classes of functions and see if
we can specific classes of randomized
algorithms and see if they can be D
randomized at least if we can prove
because some of the consequences and
that is given that is what gives rise to
the field of D randomization that we try
to conserve specific classes of
functions and try to see if there were a
randomized algorithms for counting can
be D randomized I guess I do not need to
motivate anymore so anyway approximate
counting of pts a small survey of the
field so again Rocco mentioned in the
last talk that the landscape of counting
for half spaces or linear special
functions looks really nice right now
the state of results Stefan kovitch when
Paula Bogota and gopalan climbers mecca
both independently and concurrently give
deterministic algorithms in running in
time poly n 1 over epsilon which can
count the faction of satisfying
assignments for half space
over the uniform distribution on the
hypercube so I'm always talking about
the uniform distribution on the
hypercube up till a one plus minus
epsilon multiplicative error of course
if you consider any virtual classes of
functions like degree too high or higher
pts you cannot hope to get
multiplicative guarantee and the last
talk has the state of the art in this
particular problem that if you are given
a degree to PDF then you can compute the
you can estimate fraction of satisfying
assignments to an additive epsilon in
time poly n times 2 to the poly one over
epsilon that was the last talk and now
we can ask what about which your classes
of functions coming from these ltf sent
PDFs of degree 2 so 4 that 4k hunters of
half spaces so if you consider function
of K half spaces gopalan O'Donnell vu
and Zukerman they gave a deterministic
counting algorithm for this class
running in time n to the K plus lock key
of epsilon phi epsilon additive l and in
fact if epsilon is really small epsilon
is somewhat large like it's super
inverse poly logarithmic i don't know
how to say this quantity then they
actually get a running time which is
exponential in k times poly n in fact
they accomplish something much more they
give pseudo-random generators but we're
not discussing that what about functions
of PDF so go hunt as a half spaces
though the interesting reserves what
about functions of pds so again this far
in the path is so the only previous
result relevant to assess that iconic
Alice gainer Nelson showed that k
hunters of degree two pdfs over the
normal distribution over the
n-dimensional normal distribution can be
counted up to an additive epsilon in
time n to the K times poly one over
epsilon and they achieve a similar
running time with the worst dependence
on the K when the distribution is
replaced by the uniform on the hypercube
ok so those are the so in particular the
running time for any super constant K or
sub constant epsilon becomes super
polynomial in
throw that this and this is now the kind
of this is a problem we are interested
in we want to do the same task with a
running time which remains falling in
for some super constant K and sub
constant epsilon so we want to achieve a
running time we aren't to achieve a
running time for the this problem which
is poly nth time some fixed function of
K epsilon okay so now this is the main
theorem that there is an algorithm which
runs in deterministic time poly n times
some function of K and epsilon this
function of K and epsilon is rather bad
it is like simply exponential in K&W
exponential in epsilon but it still some
function of K epsilon which given any
function G over the boolean hypercube
with boolean function with the boolean
hypercube in k dimensions and K degree
to PDFs outputs the number new which is
an epsilon accurate estimate of the
probability that when you take the
random point in the hypercube then g of
f 1 2 FK evaluates to 1 ok so as a
result clear the main result this is not
a pseudo-random generator the algorithm
will actually extensively look at the
instance and for this talk because you
can just assume g to gain and because
any function over the K dimensional
hypercube can be written as 2 to the K
different ends and we are really paying
something much more than 2 to the K so
just think of Gia's and ok and proving
this main result similar to the last
talked almost all the work goes into
proving the same result when the
distribution when the input distribution
is changed from the uniform distribution
in the hypercube to the n-dimensional
normal distribution so most of the work
goes towards getting the same algorithm
when the domain is equipped with the
standard normal measure rather than the
uniform measure and then you use in
various principles and stuff to go from
normal to the boolean thing ok so I
technique for doing the main result is
first you prove the main result over the
normal distribution and then following
the previous talk we can so this is all
this awesome work by alkenyl interest of
ryan who give a who give these budget
who give this invariance principle so it
shows that once you can do the counting
over the normal distribution you can
achieve the same approximation
guarantees for you can do the same
counting algorithm for the degree two
polynomials polynomials over the
hypercube as well over the uniform
distribution the hypercube as well
provided these polynomials irregular
meaning that every variable has very
small influence on the on each of the
polynomials so this is pretty standard
and so what you now need to do is to
show that what if some of the
polynomials are not regular so then you
want to decompose it to your case is a
given sorry
why I don't think that comes out okay
but anyway the important thing is that
ok so next week when you arrive until I
am NOT going to discuss the main regular
the regularity lemma because it kind of
follows very standard techniques but
basically be sure that if you are given
K degree two PTS k degree two polynomial
threshold functions you can construct a
decision tree of depth depending Justin
K and epsilon so ck n epsilon such that
with high probability over the leaves of
the decision tree the following will
hold that if you restrict all the
variables along the path leading from
the root going from the root to the leaf
all the resulting degree two pdfs will
become regular ok and so this so
equipped with this decision and this
decision tree can be constructed in time
which is poly n times due to the ck
epsilon so this is efficiently
constructible and that will mean that
okay once you have them as once you know
how to count for regular PDFs you can
just go over all the possible paths of
the decision tree do this counting out
of relief and you can get an estimate I
don't want to go over this thing too
much it follows kind of existing results
in the field the proof techniques follow
from existing results in the field okay
so what it boils down to is proving this
main technical result over the normal
distribution on that if I given K degree
two pts with the domain equipped with
the normal distribution then you want to
do this additive then you want to do
this approximate counting and the
roadmap towards achieving this is first
will state and use central limit theorem
then we show how the central limit
theorem is helpful to do the approximate
counting when some nice conditions are
met on the polynomial the nice
conditions will be similar to what was
used in the previous talk and then we
show okay that a general case can be
decomposed to meet these nice conditions
so you can take the general
given K degree 2 polynomials you can do
some restrictions something to meet the
hypothesis of the CLT so what I'll do is
have stayed the new CLT then go over how
its applied and finally come to the
proof of the CLT okay so basically will
prove a new CLT for the Joint
Distribution of K degree two polynomials
which all have small I ghen values what
do I mean by eigenvalue for polynomial
so we call that any degree two
polynomial px I can always write it down
in this form X transpose X plus BX plus
C where B is a vector and a is a matrix
symmetric matrix and the eigen value of
a degree two polynomial is just defined
the maximum eigen value of a degree of
polynomial is just defined to be the
maximum singular value of the matrix a I
will show that if I am given a
collection of K degree two polynomials
all of whose largest eigen values are
very tiny then their joint distribution
looks like a normal in certain metric
sorry tiny compared to the variance tiny
compared to the variance viateur so
there's yeah your combinations problem
idea I'm not saying what metric I mean
this is something weaker it was a show
it in the kolmogorov distance and the K
dimensional kolmogorov distance we will
just what we require okay so this is the
main theorem it is the main thing this
is a new central limit theorem that if
you have K degree two polynomials over
the normal distribution and all of them
satisfy 3 conditions so they satisfy 3
conditions the eigenvalues of the
maximum eigen values of each of the
polynomials is bounded by epsilon their
variance is always bounded by one and at
least one of the variances is at least
see okay then the Joint Distribution
looks like a multi-dimensional normal
and what multi-dimensional normal can it
look like if it at all looks like a
normal well the one which has the same
first and second moments as
Joint Distribution so that's what this
thing says it is that then the Joint
Distribution of the polynomials be 12 PK
looks like the joint looks like a
multi-dimensional normal with the same
mean and covariance matrix as the p12 PK
and the distance they call mother of
distance between these two distributions
is K to the two-thirds times epsilon to
the 16 / c to the 16 so if all the
polynomials had variance 1 so was
canceled simple case when all the
polynomials at variance 1 then the
cosmic distances just skated two-thirds
times epsilon to the 160 saying i am
going to define the cosmograph distance
in k dimensions is the obvious analog of
the distance in one dimension this is
like obvious or easy or anything at ps1
right there's obvious of K equals 10 it
is but well last talk showed that
basically you can if if there's only one
degree polynomial then you can do a
business change and then it looks like a
decoupling you can apply the same very
very same kind of thing okay so case k
equals 1 follows by various e and okay
what's the K dimensional cosmograph
distance is this is that you take a soup
of a soup over theta 1 2 theta K which
are real numbers and then you ask what
is the difference between the
probabilities that all Z eyes are
bounded by T ties with a V all the Z
prime eyes are bounded by she ties so if
you take theta if you take k equals 1
you're just asking what is the
probability that difference of the
probabilities that z1 lies in one side
of the real line versus V prime
modernize mod 0 theta line there's
obvious extension ok so the central
limit chill mixes
okay why is the CLG helpful why do we
care if you have the CLT so so applying
the CLT so if you are given K degree to
PDFs over with the normal distribution
as the domains and now now from now
onwards the domain measure is always the
normal distribution and fi equals sign
of P I of course you can assume that the
variance of P eyes are all one you can
just be scale the polymers you can
always assume the variance of the Piazza
one and you assume an additional
condition that the maximum eigen values
of all these P is is bounded by epsilon
okay now put g equals hand if g function
the twin towers and and which we said is
the most general thing you can only do
then all you need to compute is the
probability that all these f is our one
which is equivalent to the probability
that all these pis are greater than
equal to 0 however the probability does
all these p eyes are greater than equal
to 0 by the CLT is very close to the
probability that a multi-dimensional
normal all the coordinates of a
multi-dimensional normal are greater
than equal to 0 where the
multi-dimensional normal you can have
the same first and second moments SP 12
PK so given P 12 PK you can explicitly
compute what this multi-dimensional
normal is so if you are shooting for
approximate counting it suffices to
compute the right hand side but the
right hand side has no end it has
reduced to a finite dimensional problem
there is only there K square parameters
there K first moments and their case per
second moments you just want to compute
what is the probability this
multi-dimensional normal is always all
quadrants a greater than equal to 0
lying the positive are sent this can be
computed in time K to the K but doesn't
matter it can be computed something
depending just on K and so we are done
in this case so if you work out the
parameters from the CLT fall the
eigenvalues of the polynomial are small
enough we are done so this why the CNT
is helpful so all we should now try to
do is how am i doing on time ok so if
all the eigen values are small enough
then we anger shape so now what we
should do is to try to do some procedure
by which we can bring the
polynomial stuff small eigenvalues so
what happens in 41 if some of the
polynomials have large eigenvalues so
we'll consider a toy case of what we'll
do so assume that all the polynomials
are diagonalizable in the same basis
okay diagonalizable in the same basis
means that see all the pis okay so all
the pis can be so p i can be written as
X transpose AIX plus bi times X plus C
if all the matrices a ir diagonalizable
in the same basis then we will consider
this toy case and then it means if they
are diagonalizable in the same basis
then you can write P I as summation
alpha J LJ X square plus beta IJ LJ x
plus CI okay by LG excess of the linear
forms which diagonalize the matrix AI
and they all diagonals double in the
same basis and because of the great
property that they housed inside
invariant under orthonormal
transformations the Joint Distribution
of P 12 PK which is what we are
interested in remains the same if I just
rename the variables from li to call it
why I so these are just new independent
normals you can just call them that and
so now these are the polynomials were
interested in so this is this is the
Joint Distribution we're interested in
understanding and so now they're two
conditions so if lambda if so early if
all the eigen values are small the
maximum eigen values of all the pies are
small that translates to just saying
that all these all these alpha j's are
all small so then we already know we are
done if not then following an analysis
in this paper by the purchase ryan he
and david it can be shown that there is
some sort of a decomposition you can do
that there is a small set of variables
but of size K over epsilon square such
that for any P I at least one of the
following
to either it will happen that with high
probability if you restrict all the
variables in L then the sign of P is
close to a constant meaning that
essentially this P I just depends on the
variables in L or if you restrict the
variables in L then the eigen value of
the resulting polynomial becomes small
compared to experience in which you can
which case you can roughly apply the CLT
so either a polynomial is just dependent
on the small set of variables all after
you restrict the values the resulting
polynomial has a small eigen value
compared to its variance so you can
apply the CLT or it has become a
constant so you can become close to a
constant so just replace it by a
constant I'm not being super clear here
but this is a hazy idea and this all in
the toy case though when all of them are
diagonalizable in the same basis so if
you can do this okay so this is now this
is a win-win analysis so first restrict
all the variables in l the only k of
epsilon square variables that
restriction takes time two to the K of
epsilon square going over all
possibilities and for each I in case you
are one of the following either after
the restriction the sign of P I has
become close to a constant so then just
pretend it's a constant replace it it's
trivial now all lambda max FBI is small
compared to its variance and you can
apply the CLT and clearly all this can
be done in time Polly n times some
function of K epsilon so this was the
toy case what happens if all of them are
not diagonalizable in the same basis so
then you can't you do this orthogonal
transformation in the very beginning
because there is no basis in which all
of them look diagonal all the
polynomials of diagonal but you can try
to do it one by one so and the key
concept again we are going to use here
is that linear forms of gaussian
Circassians so basically if you have
another suppose you are given a function
f of x 1 to x and y x1 to xn are drawn
from a standard no n dimensional normal
given any linear form l1 x whose to
norma's ones are given if you are given
a linear foremost to normals one
consider an orthonormal completion of
this basis l12 ln then f of x1 to xn can
be z express this g of l12 ln well the
proper certain properties like if s
where the quadratic polynomial continue
to be a quadratic polynomial so if you
can now start making given any linear
form you can rewrite f in the basis
where you make l1 as one of the
variables and so it makes sense to the
strict on all possible values of L 1 so
this is the key observation we are using
and so again we'll start doing the same
way either say either the conditions of
the CLT are met that is eigenvalues are
small and then you can just apply the
CLT if not there is a linear form L
without otherwise just assume that
lambda max of p1 is big just assume the
lambda max of p1 is big you can do so
without loss of generality and then
there is a linear form l 1 such that if
you express p 1 in the basis of l1 and
some also normal extension of l1 then p
1 can be written as alpha 1 L 1 X square
plus beta 1 L 1 x times r1 plus q1 I one
here is linear q1 is quadratic and r1
doesn't involve the linear form l1 and
neither this q1 and in fact I 1 and q 1
i'm independent of l1 because they are
only involving the variables l 22 Ln
which was horizontal one and furthermore
the variance of q1 is at most 1 minus
epsilon so in particular you can
consider restricting on all possible
values of L 1 this is not exactly
possible because L 1 has a Gaussian
distribution this sort of finite
supports you can't go over all
restrictions but you can discretize and
do something yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
substitute so you just yes the say of
what happens when L 1 is this value this
value so you can't go then find support
but discretizing go over all possible
values and what happens now is so you
can continue doing this recursive lamb
being a hazy here but this the main idea
goes to very easily that we can continue
recursively until all the QI satisfied
one of the two possibilities either
after the restriction lambda max of Qi
so the variance of Qi is substantially
large compared to its eigenvalue back
the maghuin value or the variance of Qi
has become very small if the variance of
QR has become very small after all the
restrictions is a move it and then you
have essentially gotten something very
similar to a hunter not really a junta
bit of winter blahs linear form and if
not in the first case you have a
conditioned up like the CLT basically
this can go on fact most K of epsilon
square steps the reason being that at
every stage you at least take epsilon
faction of the variance of at least one
of the guys the only k guys so total you
can go on first k of epsilon square
steps being easy here but basically it
means that after all this after going
over KO phi epsilon square steps where
you can algorithmically do this
restriction using the case but you can
apply a mix of the CLT or brute force
and do the thing it's not hard it's not
hard it's a bit tedious but it's not
hard okay so that leaves me with the CLT
okay so okay so I still have 10 minutes
or 15 months that's good okay so now the
main central let's recap what is the
central limit term we are trying to
prove here so all that all that is left
is we are trying to provide central
limit theorem now let p 12 PK be
quadratic polynomials which whose
variance is bounded by one maximum eigen
values are bounded by epsilon and at
least one of them has a variance lower
bounded by C then the Joint Distribution
goes to a normal in canoga of distance
with the this being the bound on the
column above distance okay how do you
prove this so there are two key words
here one is x method and the second
keyword is molly have in calculus i am
going to go over the first one and the
second one so first let me go with
Stein's method so Stein's method is
inspired by this very easy to prove but
important fact that if you have an
absolutely continuous F and who's a
rounded derivative
is always bounded and if Z denotes the
standard normal then expect yeah I'm
Mike an elephant value back so we'd have
x 30 okay if Z is a stand okay so let me
refer to as the ademas nice functions so
here is a nice function and Z is a
standard normal then the following
identity holds good expectation of Z
times f z equals expectation of F prime
Z this is a very simple fact and how do
you prove it this integration by parts
just write the expressions of Z times f
ZN f prime z integrate you will see the
other thing this is a very simple proof
turns out that this is a the converse is
also true so if for a random variable z
it holds that every for every absolutely
continuous f with a bounded f prime this
identity holds good then z is the
standard normal how do you prove this
part so some basic differential
equations not very difficult empty
amount of calculus not very difficult
but turns out this means that this
equation is a characterizing of is a
characteristic of I mean it
characterized the standard normals
exactly and so the next question to ask
is is this characterization robust that
means can we say mega meta statements
like this that if expectation of z FZ
minus expectation of f prime Z is always
small for very large class of functions
then z is close to a normal in some
metric and we make this kind of thing
and then so this is the basis behind
Stannis method so an example of a
theorem from stine steins method is the
following lemma that if you if you are
given a random variable W such that
expectation of s prime W minus w fw is
always bounded is bounded by epsilon
it's absolute value is bounded by
epsilon where s can be chosen to be any
function whose infinity norm is also
bounded and the derivatives infinity
norm is also bounded then the total
variation distance between w and the
normal is bounded by epsilon you can say
okay what about if I try to prove
something like a weaker distance metric
like the Vasa stand distance well then
you have to prove the smallness of this
quantity for an even smaller class of
functions so you can restrict yourself
to a class of functions whose first
second who's not just the function is
bounded but this person second
derivatives also bounded ok so the am
just giving prototype of theorems that
can be when using signs method ok so
what are we so remember we are trying to
prove convergence to multivariate normal
it's not a single normal we are trying
to prove closeness to their similar
characterizing equations for
multivariate normal and fortunately I
will not go into it because take a lot
of effort some not going to go into how
to prove closest to multivariate normal
but it's basically the same kind of
characterizing operators have to bounce
certain numbers certain things so just
focus on the univariate case of steins
method and how Stein's method is used in
this content and context the polynomials
of gaussians no we won't we won't
converge for more normal in the
earthmover metric but will converge to a
first mover metric stack size back test
functions for the first derivative is
mounted you can show that the
convergence is in a respected test
functions whose second David is founded
but second derivative is good enough
first because we just want call moga of
distance earthmoving metric is stronger
than corner of distance right so okay so
okay so how will we apply stein live by
the principle of conservation of
difficulty so we are now trying to prove
convert that some pauline also consider
the basic case that you're trying to
prove some polynomial of gaussians is
close to a normal you apply steins
method so now basically you have to
prove that for every function if W
denotes the know if W denotes the
polynomial of gaussians then for every
function f say from this class F prime W
minus w fw is bounded and you have just
transferred the difficulty to this kind
of a problem how
analyze this expectation how do you
prove this expectation is bounded and
this is so so just for the moment don't
hang out was sustained or total vation
just how do you bound these kind of
quantities and this is where the next
keyword enter so I Apollo variables here
random evils of the form polynomials of
gaussians and this is where the next
keyword enters mal you have in calculus
in the natural male oven calculus allows
us to take derivatives of stochastic
processes I am afraid to say anything
more than this because afraid I'll say
something wrong this is a this is
informally what it is and the derivative
in gallium in calculus is basically
somehow taking derivative with respect
to the chance parameter Omega so if
Omega is the sample space Omega capital
Omega is a sample space you are
basically taking derivative with respect
to elements of the sample space we don't
require all these interpretations I'm
going to define this syntactically in
the next slide and going to see is very
simple so all the complexity comes from
infinite dimensional Gaussian processes
we are sticking tube dimension in so
here is some definition of the male
event derivative let us be a function on
R to the N real valued function and the
domain is equipped with the standard
normal measure assume F is a nice
function so you require certain
smoothness conditions so basically you
require something like the derivatives
have polynomially bounded growth for us
it's polynomials everything is
polynomially bounded growth then the
malayan derivative operator d-max f2a r
to the n valued random variable whose is
component is just the partial of F with
respect to X I the reason these
definition becomes complicated is when
you are dealing with infinite
dimensional Brownian in finite
dimensional domains then you cannot know
you can no longer write D of F i equals
del F over partial so I
so consider the function being just x 1
square plus x 2 square plus xn square
then the first component is just 2x 1 so
X 1 itself is a random variable right so
this remains now R to the N valued
random variable okay the mean I think
technical issues come when you take like
Brownian motions you're considering
functions of Brownian motion that is
when these things become really
complicated and used but for us the
thing is very finite dimensional and
everything is very nice so you can in
particular right dfi equals del F over
del X I otherwise you cannot write that
there is a basis independent definition
of this thing so it's a calculus so
there are lots of nice things that hold
good in particular so I'm just giving my
example it's a calculus lots of nice
properties lots of nice things hold good
for example let F H be a vector in R to
the N so just be an element on R to the
N and WH denote the Gaussian random
variable in the direction of exercises
summation H ixi then you can very easily
prove that expectation of x times W of
HF is some random variable on in this
Gaussian space equals the expectation of
the inner product of DF with H note that
DF is a random variable so it makes
sense to take in expectations and this
is the analog of integration by parts in
this calculus lots of nice identities
hold good that's what I'm trying to say
I'm not going to use it anywhere I'm
almost still have some time ok so why do
why am I talking about malavan calculus
so this is the reason I'm talking about
Molly have in calculus so this was found
this was first in a paper by new alert
and peccati from 2004 and it's a very
simple identity that if w is a random
variable in the space of the Indus
functions of gulf since it's a function
of gulf since I was nice enough again
polynomially bounded derivatives and all
that then the following identity holds
good expectation of s prime W minus w fw
equals expectation of F prime W times
this quantity 1 minus inner product of
DW and minus d l inverse w ok I have
explained what the operator D does it
just takes derivative with respect to
the effect size I need to explain what
the operator L inverse thus and it's
very simple assume the function has a
hermit expansion just attenuate the QSR
level of the Hermit expansion by minus 1
over Q that's all it does so and you're
not going to do anything with the level
0 so they're not 0 part will take you be
taken out it will vanish and the IQ is
part of the Hermit expansion will be
attenuated by minus 1 over Q and this
identity holds good again it's an
identity if you know the right calculus
identities in this thing it's not a very
hot statement to prove I mean can I
these expressions are easy to express
with the premier expansion tu is just a
gradient royalty yeah so can you just
write the romito expansion of everything
and I take your Papa I think so yes yes
any doctor when I think it will pop out
very easily yeah there's an identity so
not too much it can go only one way from
left to right yeah I think it will pop
out too easily again most of the
complexity comes when you have in finite
dimensional thing so maybe there's an
easier way of doing all this rather than
using the hammer ok but this looks
useful right so on the left hand side is
a term we wanted to bound instance
method and this is saying it's exactly
equal to this term the Scylla F prime W
popping around which will get will get
rid of it in the next slide so we
excessive is equivalent to bounding the
right hand side we now I just want to
bound the right hand side ok so the
first equation is just what i wrote
earlier again you can show the following
thing if the variance of W is one and
the mean of W is zero you can show the
mean of this quantity is equal to one
again not difficult to show maybe just
doing the heavy thing will show this
thing and hence now now next observe
that says f is f is a kind of function
we are that is coming from Stein's
method we're always the first derivative
was bounded hence by Cauchy Schwarz here
it suffices to bound the variance of
this random variable so this is this is
tremendous important now we have reduced
this closeness to normal to just
bounding the variance of a random
variable but W is an explicit thing we
are trying to prove close to normal just
take this DWD l inverse w work it out
syntactically and you're just trying to
prove the variance is bounded this is
something much simpler potentially much
simpler so that's all it boils down to
so it all boils down to controlling the
variance of this quantity so this is how
Stein's method and Malia in calculus
interact with each other for us some I
supposed to stop at two-thirty because
I'm really close to 2 30 ok the finish
it as quickly as possible so we are
trying to build closeness to
multivariate normal so far was just
talking about univariate normals so the
tact izing operators become slightly
more complicated to write on the board i
am not going to do that but here is an
example of a true theorem which is
already was known to be true in
literature that if you consider the
class of functions on our to the k2 I
who's from our to the k2 are the second
derivatives bounded and let's see one
two ck be a Gaussian distribution with
the same mean and covariance as w 12 WK
then norden and peccati showed that w 12
WK + v 12 ZK are close to each other
with respect to the class of test
functions H with something bounded by k
square epsilon as long as you can show
that the variance of this quantity D WI
minus d l inverse WJ is always bounded
by epsilon for any choice of ing this is
like when it was one dimensional then
you had DWI DWI now we'll say all
possible eyes and j's from 1 to k you if
all of the variances can be bounded then
you can show this ok so what should we
do but we want to prove this theorem so
first we wanted to show so we just show
this theorem that if WI is a quadratic
polynomial whose variance is 1 and
lambda max is bounded by epsilon ok so
all W eyes and w JS then we sure that
this quantity is bounded by epsilon
and then how do you prove this just
calculation and little bit of matrix
analysis not difficult just the page or
so and that proves that if we have been
given a collection of degree 2
polynomials whose eigenvalues are
bounded then it's close to a
multivariate normal with respect to this
class of test functions edge meaning the
class of test functions which have a set
of bounded second bounded second
derivative we want do it closeness in
colma graph this is not a hard job from
here right i mean what will you do we
will take the interval function
smoothing it out standard stuff nothing
nothing very know how fitting is going
on this is what said what we do but yeah
it gets everybody knows what is to be
done ok so we cap we have the central
limit theorem and if you have to send so
CLT allows us to send the recap CLG
allows us to do approximate counting as
long as all the eigenvalues are really
tiny if some of the eigenvalues are
large we can apply this decomposition to
reduce it to a combination of CLT plus
brute force and you can use a regularity
lemma to move from the normal to the
boolean hypercube Thanks it's also the
fourth moment stuff right where if you
show that if the polynomial has the
fourth moment that's like three paper
than anything exactly so there's also a
p-dimensional version of the Fourth
Movement stuff what's that is there like
a multi dimensional version done oh I
don't think so I don't know i don't know
maybe there is I'm the fourth most stuff
says that if something is restricted to
a level of the Wiener chaos so you have
to jessica says only which is
homogeneous
distribution in several dimensions where
any linear function of the output is gas
okay but maybe some easier to check
first morning of like you know can you
like use that theorem I guess the k
equals 1 case was so easy for you anyway
right yeah could you also proved it by
the Fourth Movement thing I mean not
that it's may be necessary the fourth
one more thing but again the first
moment thing if you just appoint applied
that same as a black box the fourth
moment thing has to assume that the
polynomial you are given lies completely
in the winner's curse of degree two sets
a completely homemade degree 2 thing we
have Jaime degree two blurs degree one
thing i don't think the degree one
shouldn't a morally add to the
complexity say easier thing we know how
to handle what is the gaussian you know
exactly what they're all sin is i just
don't know how to apply the same as a
black box but i think everything is
always more complicated i think this is
how they prove the theorem I think like
most of the the bulk is actually getting
that identity once you get that identity
from there like it's an identity if you
know that to be true the list of the
things just follow and I think the okay
maybe this complexity if you are dealing
with in finite dimensional things maybe
those complexity other questions
comments well in such a case i want to
remind the audience that we are an open
problem session also today so you know
think about open problems it takes a 340
and otherwise we'll reconvene again at
three that was good thank you